While you are working to decrease
the time it takes to complete the form,
you've got a few options at
your disposal to help out.
First off,
you could use your user's existing data.
For example, if the user is logged into
your site, and you already know their
postal code because they submitted it in
a earlier form, it will be nice of you
to pre-fill the postal code field with
a known one like you could see here.
Another option is to access
the geolocation in order to
determine the postal code.
This works even if
the user isn't logged in.
Check the instructor notes for
more details.
This is great because
with almost no efforts,
you saved your users time and
you're one field closer to completion.
In the date example,
here it's three fields closer.
Great, no?
Another easy option is to enable
users automatically fill fields
by enabling autofill.
You will dive deep into autofill
attribute by enabling
Auto Complete in the next lesson.
But before thinking about our
attributes on your inputs,
I want you to think about
the input elements themselves.
Just look how powerful autofill can be.
I'm just start typing here and
when I'm choosing,
it's automatically fill the form.